okay well breaking news we've just got
the very latest daily covid statistics
into us here at sky news there have been
a hundred and nineteen thousand seven
hundred and eighty nine new cases of
covid 19 recorded in the last 24 hours
another 147 deaths have been reported
within 28 days of a positive test well
that brings the total number of deaths
in the uk to 147
hundred and twenty well let's go
straight to sky's ashna harinac who's in
the newsroom for us this afternoon ashna
yet more record-breaking data yeah this
is the highest number this figure has
been since the pandemic began when it
comes to those cases 119
789 recorded in the last 24 hours this
is on top of the cases that we saw
yesterday yesterday as we heard was a
record-breaking date in itself that
figure sat at around 106 000 but there
we go in the last 48 hours
more than 100 cases of covert 19 more
than 100 000 infections being recorded
and that really does give you a sense of
the scale the prevalence really how
much covert 19 has spread throughout the
uk and we know that this is the omicron
effect this this is the one that is
sweeping through the uk we know this
because the percentage of delta cases is
incredibly low in places like the east
of england in london in the south west
of england but also in the south east
the cases of delta remain stunningly low
it is the omicron variant that is
thriving just look at these figures 1 in
45 people in england currently have
covert 19 in wales one in 4 1 in 55 one
in 50 in northern ireland and one in 70
in scotland in northern ireland that is
the same as the week before but in
scotland uh that number uh sitting at
one in 70 last week it was one in 80. in
london though it's one in 30 people that
currently have covert 19 among them are
many nhs members of staff across england
18
829 nhs staff were off work due to
covert 19 as of the 19th of december
that is 54 higher than the week before
but if we focus in on the capital where
this virus has really taken off the
increase in staff absence due to covert
19 was 152
on the previous week either those people
though are offset sick or they are
self-isolating london of course has seen
the biggest increase in cases hence
hospital admissions here in the capital
rising by 56
now covert bed occupancy is not only up
here in the capital but it's also
showing a slight increase in places like
the north west of england or that
although that data is in the very early
stages the one glimmer of good news that
we can hold on to though is that the
number of patients who are in intensive
care have not in greece increased so
even though people are going into
hospital they are not severely affected
by this disease
okay ashley thanks very much indeed for
that